we actually moved to Palm Beach County
for the 10 rated schools in our
neighborhood we actually bought our
house based on that number
everything hinged on where our kids are
going to go to school we have four
children three of whom are in the
elementary setting so
um it's just really important to us
I'm just uncomfortable with a lot of the
topics being taught
I have pulled my own children out of
school so we now go to a Christian
School by choice
where have the four academics gone and
how can we get that back
why does their emotional regulations
need to be taught from step one to step
ten you know what do they assume that
we're not doing that as a family
and you just wonder kind of what's
behind it so we do this by reading them
books daily we are constantly being told
that there's not enough money in our
school system yet we find out that not
only are all these things taking place
in our school system with our tax
dollars diverting money that should be
spent on classrooms on learning on
programming but there's also a lot of
outside money coming in
we did a deep dive into five foundations
that were funding Public Schools The
Gates Foundation obviously related to
Bill Gates they prioritize equity and
Dei and in their giving they apply an
intersectional gender lens to their
strip strategies and Investments the
chance Zuckerberg initiative obviously
related to Mark Zuckerberg of facebook
slash meta they focus on giving to
dismantle systemic racism and inequality
and help schools develop anti-racist
educational environments
um The Wallace Foundation which is one
that a lot of people are not aware of um
they're giving focuses on fostering
Equity primarily through social
emotional learning programs the Kellogg
Foundation related to the cereal they
are they have a commitment to advancing
racial equity and racial healing and the
windward fund which is related to
Arabelle advisors one of the notorious
massive dark money organizations on the
left uses a race Equity diversity and
inclusiveness commitment to advance
their giving so between 2017 and 2021 we
reviewed 990s from all these foundations
and we found that there was over 200
million dollars between the five
foundations that had been spent in 72
school districts across the country
the biggest concern for moms and dads on
the ground is the fact that the money
wasn't focused on promoting and
improving academic achievement but again
was really focused on affecting student
behavior and professional development
for teachers and oftentimes putting a
focus on Equity or Equitable grading
when parents were really looking for
merit-based standards
this is not just happening in big cities
it's not just happening in blue States
it's happening in red States it's
happening in small cities and the volume
of spending that's happening is really
it's astonishing
the two biggest grants or the two
biggest recipients of this funding that
we've found were in Battle Creek
Michigan they received 31.2 million
dollars and Denver which received 13.4
million dollars
Palm Beach County received a total of
seven million dollars over the past
several years they got massive grants on
social emotional learning from The
Wallace Foundation
you know some of the time was being you
know just being wasted on a lot of
topics that we we discussed at home and
we work on those things as a family
specifically critical race theory was
slowly seeping into the classrooms the
social emotional learning was a problem
for me
a number of these programs Equity social
emotional learning are actually being
used to push a lot of identity-based
programming the parents are deeply
uncomfortable with because it conflicts
their values
every hour that's being diverted from
Reading Writing and arithmetic and being
spent on social emotional learning
programs feelings bullying is time
that's not being spent in making up
learning laws
our scores are going down so these
programs are not working
a lot of these this content is being
introduced at very young ages and so
when you have a six-year-old a
seven-year-old in first grade second
grade being taught about systems of
Oppression that's a really complex
Theory and it's something that these
children can't wrap their heads around I
mean in many cases these kids are still
trying to learn their ABCs and now
they're being told too that they must
integrate pronouns into things well they
don't know what a pronoun is they're
still learning to read and write
we worked with 26 other parental rights
organizations from across the country
Coast to Coast
um asking these foundations to cease
their giving on these Equity focused
initiatives because we believe that
although they might be well intentioned
the underlying message that some of
these programs have are detrimental to
student learning to student mental
health and end up distracting from
student achievement
the goal of the letters that are going
to the foundations is to acknowledge
that we all want children to do well in
school we'd like to talk to you about
how you're spending that money how
schools are being forced to spend that
money we again as parents would like to
see the focus put back on academic
achievement where our children are
giving being given practicable skills
and we believe that this money that's
going into the school districts from
these philanthropic organizations could
be put to better use
so we hope that Governors and other
elected officials who are focused on
education who are focused on academic
outcomes out of their schools take a
hard look about on how their schools are
receiving money from outside
organizations
a public school system if they are to
provide an academic foundation for our
students and they're severely lacking
and they're failing because the money's
being spent on you know emotional
training things like this